[Music]
you all watching the olympics yes
no they're getting uh they're getting
mixed reviews yeah people are angry at
nbc for showing a promo that revealed
the winner of a swimming event even
though the race hadn't aired yet
yeah yeah this afternoon nbc apologized
saying we're just not used to people
watching our network
[Applause]
so this is what it's like
that was fun uh
here's the latest olympic officials have
determined it's too cold for the women's
beach volleyball competitors to wear
bikinis
in a related story today bill clinton
came out in favor of global warming
this is crazy an australian swimmer who
failed to win a gold medal is blaming
her loss on social media
yeah inner defense it is really hard to
tweet when you're swimming
what do you give me for that one that's
that's does that get bronze or silver
that one
i i think it's fourth
and yeah
you're helping me out left and right
tonight well it was more true than funny
yeah exactly
good news
what if you did that in the monologue
every night
more true than funny yeah yeah
you're losing them yeah
work harder irish
i'll get you back
hey i got good news good news today
olympic officials said saudi arabia's
first female athlete will be allowed to
compete while wearing a headscarf
yeah
yeah the saudi woman said she's thrilled
about the ruling all she needs now is a
man to drive her to the olympics
that uh
mitt romney back on u.s soil oh i i
sensed that
what happened i just can see your breath
what do you mean what are you talking
about i just felt oh there's something
midi
there's a midi quality yeah
some conservatives are saying that mitt
romney's trip overseas was a disaster
and he should have stayed home
yeah in response romney said but some of
my favorite homes are overseas
[Laughter]
and then he ate gold
[Applause]
that's my new mitt romney impression
him eating out of bags of gold
some historians now believe president
obama is directly descended from a slave
believe that yeah
when he heard this donald trump
immediately demanded to see the receipt
over the over the weekend lady gaga
published partially nude photos of
herself on the internet
yeah
yeah lady gaga's fans wrote back saying
thanks but we're gay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]